Barcelona masculino todavía necesita
ocho puntos para celebrar el título de
la liga pero el femenino ya levantó su
copa lo hizo después de una victoria
tres cero sobre el Sporting de huelva
que mantiene Alexia putellas y compañía
invictas en la Liga de mujeres de hecho
es el triunfo consecutivo escuchó bien
el número 61 para este equipo en la liga
local y el 26 este año llega cuando
Todavía faltan cuatro jornadas y cuando
regresaba la acción la doble ganadora
del Balón de Oro Alexia putellas luego
de 10 meses fuera de acción por esa
lesión que la sacó de la Euro Sara Cómo
explicamos un dominio tan absoluto como
el que ha tenido el Barcelona femenino
lo primero es inversión según el último
reporte o estudios que se han hecho
sobre fútbol femenino es el equipo que
más ha invertido 7.2 millones de euros
al año aproximadamente obviamente esto
Comparado con los equipos masculinos no
es no es un monto todavía sigue
existiendo una brecha enorme Pero tiene
que ver con inversión y la consolidación
de un proyecto sólido estamos hablando
que este equipo tiene 21 títulos de los
cuales 11 de ellos los ha conseguido los
últimos cuatro años Estamos hablando de
cuatro ligas tres copas de la reina tres
supercopas de España y una Champions
League y ya tiene lista por tercera vez
consecutiva disputar esta final de
Champions de este año que se llevará a
cabo este tres de junio está esperando
el rival entre voltsburgo y Arsenal pero
sin duda este este Barcelona es un
equipo de época un equipo de esos que va
a marcar historia creo que el regreso de
Alexia putellas en este momento también
va a ser importante está teniendo sus
primeros minutos estuvo 299 días fuera
de las canchas Pero tiene que ver con un
proyecto Sólido consolidado y de creer
en la inversión que requiere el fútbol
de élite masculino o